Sometimes, dealing with anomalies that could
destroy the world with a flick of their wrist
can get a little old.
Sure, it definitely wouldn’t be a good thing
if the Devourer of Worlds...Well, devoured
the world, or if SCP-001 - When Day Breaks
- turned us all into weird, melty zombies.
But it’s almost impossible to conceive the
sheer scale of destruction that an XK-Class
End of the World Scenario would cause.
You’d be almost numb to it, if you even
survived.
In the words of SCP-2430 creator Josef Stalin,
“The death of one man is a tragedy.
The death of millions is a statistic.”
Okay, he didn’t actually say that, but it’s
an appropriate quote either way.
Today, we’re talking about a much smaller,
pettier kind of evil.
Sure, this anomaly can kill people - and has,
many, many times, in fact - but where it really
gets its kicks, is in making you feel like
crap on a more emotional level.
It’s SCP-056: Ironically known by the nickname,
“A Beautiful Person”, because on the inside,
this self-obsessed monster is anything but
beautiful.
This crafty creature spent what potentially
could have been hundreds of years around humans
before the SCP Foundation eventually located
and apprehended it, meaning you may have even
run into it at some point or another before
it was rightfully imprisoned.
How do you know if you had a brush with SCP-056?
Well, it’s difficult to know for sure, but
perhaps the biggest indicator is that it probably
annoyed the living hell out of you.
You see, SCP-056 is a sentient shapeshifter
with a subtle mind-warping ability, whose
entire reason for existence is using those
abilities to make everyone around them feel
incredibly inadequate.
They don’t have any kind of consistent or
“true” form, only a consistent ethos - And
that ethos is “Anything you can do, I can
do better.”
And we mean this in its most literal sense.
Whenever SCP-056 is left with a person, an
animal, or even an object, the second all
eyes are taken off of it, it’ll become a
slightly better version of whatever it’s
encountering.
If the thing in question is capable of thinking
or feeling, it will not feel good about this
development.
Just like we said, it’s probably not going
to bring the world to its knees, but it sure
would suck to know SCP-056.
Its lack of a consistent form makes SCP-056
a little difficult to think about visually
- Which was also the reason it was so hard
to catch - but for the sake of consistency,
we’ll present it here with one of its favorite
forms: A woman who’s a real dead ringer
for “perfection” - famous actress Scarlett
Johanssen, of Black Widow fame.
So what is it really like to experience SCP-056’s
anomalous effects first-hand?
Well, we’ll take you through a little crash-course
in anomalous insecurity and frustration.
Let’s say that this creature, in human form,
is one of your co-workers.
When the Foundation discovered it, it was
working in the fashion industry, but who knows
what job it could have held before then?
If it worked in your office, it was probably
that one irritating coworker who always wore
nicer clothes than you, had a brighter, whiter
smile, and much better hair.
While you were thanklessly toiling away on
the reports for the latest financial quarter,
056 was schmoozing with your boss on golf
lunches, scoring perfect games and promotions
one “hole in one” at a time.
Of course, they tell you about it at the water
cooler.
Like everyone who’s feeling inadequate,
maybe you buy yourself a new car.
A vintage Cadillac convertible that makes
you look more like a gangster than an office
drone.
Awesome!
That’ll make all those feelings that you’re
not good enough go away.
You even buy yourself a
stylish pair of sunglasses,
and start cruising around town with the top
down, hoping that everyone sees how cool you
are now.
But when you’re stopped at a stop light,
you see something approaching in the lane
next to you.
It’s the latest Rolls Royce, in jet black.
And who would be behind the wheel but SCP-056,
in Armani shades that are much nicer than
yours.
It grins and nods to you in the mirrors, and
you can feel your soul shriveling up inside
you, only to be replaced by rage and resentment.
Maybe later that month,
you and all your co-workers
are at a bar, enjoying drinks.
Of course, SCP-056 is the best dressed one
there, and is telling all the most interesting
stories.
Your jokes don’t get any laughs, but 056
is bringing down the house with every word.
Feeling ignored, you decide to get everyone
a round on you.
056 is a designated driver in its new Rolls
Royce, so you just decide to get them a Pepsi
instead.
However, by the time you return to their stool,
they’re nowhere to be seen.
A tall glass of Coca Cola with ice cubes is
sitting on the bar next to their seat.
Perhaps one day you finally snap and decide
you can’t take it anymore.
You’ll meet SCP-056 after work and put this
showboating jerk in its place at long last.
You sneak up on it in an alley with a knife
in your palm and swing for it, but your blade
never makes contact.
SCP-056 unleashes some high-level Jiu-Jitsu
move on you, easily knocks the knife from
your hands, and beats the living hell out
of you.
When you’re later convicted of attempted
murder, all you can do is scream “They made
me do it!”
Again and again in your prison cell.
Envy can do crazy things to a person.
But there’s more!
Really, if you lose your mind from an encounter
with SCP-056, you still haven’t done too
badly.
While its methods of attack are more commonly
psychological, as we alluded to earlier, SCP-056
is definitely not above committing some pretty
horrifying acts of violence.
SCP-056 was discovered in its clothing design
job after causing an unusually high number
of murders, suicides, and mental breakdowns
among its coworkers.
However, things took an even more unpleasant
turn when the Foundation sent personnel to
detain it.
SCP-056 reacted poorly to this show of potential
force, and turned into something even more
dangerous than the Foundation planned for
in getting it under control.
We don’t know exactly what it transformed
into due to SCP Foundation redactions, but
our guesses for what it transformed into would
either be a giant monster,
a Rambo-esque unstoppable
super-soldier, or something like one of those
huge killer robots from Robocop.
Pick your favorite down there in the comments,
but whatever the case, it caused the unfortunate
deaths of seventeen agents and ten civilians.
The incident was blamed on an employee at
the company going postal and deciding to kill
a bunch of innocents, which...Technically
wasn’t untrue?
Not long after, Foundation operatives were
able to tranquilize SCP-056.
Perhaps you think this nasty little monster
decided to mellow out a little bit after being
contained, but if you did think that, I’m
afraid you’d be dead wrong.
It just decided to start terrorizing Foundation
staff with its infuriating anomalous abilities
instead.
Wait until you see this!
Compared to a lot of entities locked up at
the SCP Foundation, SCP-056 really lives in
the lap of luxury.
It has a well-furnished room, easy access
to members of staff, and is given permission
to interact with any object it desires - As
long as those objects aren’t anomalous.
Why is this Euclid-Class anomaly with over
seventeen dead Foundation staff members to
its name given so much leeway?
Well, to answer that, remember the ethos:
“Anything you can do, I can do better.”
And this holds true, whether we’re talking
physical appearance or one’s capacity to
commit tremendous acts of violence.
The Foundation is forced to cater to most
of SCP-056’s whims, or it’ll become a
hell of a lot more dangerous in response to
any kind of external resistance.
See?
We told you it’d suck to have to know this
thing, and nobody knows that better than the
employees of the SCP Foundation who are forced
to interact with it on a
daily basis for containment
and testing.
First, let’s take a look at some of the
forms it’s occupied since it began its time
at the SCP Foundation.
When a researcher brought in their beloved
pooch, SCP-056 decided to flex on it by becoming
a beautiful, well-groomed labrador retriever.
When younger female staff passed it, it decided
to once again take on its Scarlett Johanssen
form.
When speaking to a group of other researchers
about intelligence, it became a female researcher
with an IQ score thirty points higher than
the top-scoring human researcher on site.
When it took a trip to the containment site’s
gym, where the guards and mobile task forces
exercise and train, it decided to take its
flexes to a more literal level.
It transformed into a ripped, hunky bodybuilder,
who strutted into the middle of the gym and
bench-pressed 250 kilos, no problem.
This was thirty kilos more than the strongest
human guard working at the site.
Its commitment to being the best is so great
that when left alone in its containment chamber,
it will sometimes literally transform into
a nicer couch than the one the Foundation
provided for it.
Doesn’t it just make your blood boil?
But wait, there’s more!
Just in case this wasn’t absurd enough,
the Foundation felt like testing the limits
of its anomalous abilities.
In particular, they were extremely eager to
see if 056 had a secret default form.
They left it alone with a single security
camera in order to observe what it transformed
into when not being observed.
And can you guess what happened?
It turned into an even higher-quality security
camera, and stared back.
While the transformations can only take place
while 056 isn’t being observed, it’s very
astute at creating periods where it can’t
be seen or interacted with.
Vision or camera feeds have been known to
briefly go foggy in order to facilitate a
transformation.
It’s fitting that 056, being the ultimate
diva, will only ever let people look at it
on its own terms.
It also seems to get off on causing shame
- and the degree to which that statement is
metaphorical is, well, open to interpretation.
Staff members made insecure by its antics
feel compelled to enter its cell and verbally
berate it, at which point 056 will shame them
even harder, and send them out with their
tail between their legs.
It’s like every toxic friend rolled into
one nasty package.
Curious as to what else SCP-056 was capable
of, the Foundation conducted a few other tests
between SCP-056 and their personnel.
Here, they discovered that 056 seemed incredibly
responsive to intent.
When a D-Class was sent in with a knife and
the intent to kill, 056 transformed into a
lean, athletic man, before disarming and killing
the D-Class.
A somewhat attractive D-Class female was sent
in with a bottle of wine.
056 became a beautiful woman and accepted
the wine, before taking a sip, and spitting
it back into the D-Class’ face.
A mixed-gender pair of D-Classes were sent
in next with no real intent.
056 became an attractive woman in a well-tailored
business suit, who looked over the pair before
kicking them both out.
Ten male D-Classes were sent in after that.
056 turned into a beautiful woman in a low-cut
dress, and simply waited until the ten men
were driven mad with desire and began physically
fighting one another for her affection.
She watched them doing this for seven minutes
before laughing and leaving the simp squadron
to duke it out alone.
In another test, a female staff member with
Level 4 clearance, who was also judged to
be the most attractive woman on site - which
seems like an HR issue that the Ethics Committee
should probably look into - was sent into
056’s testing chamber.
056 became, quote, “An extremely aesthetically
pleasing woman, who displayed a large lexicon
and understanding of management skills.”
Unquote.
The two spoke for around 90 minutes until
the Level 4 staff member stormed out in a
rage.
Recently, 056 has requested access to the
internet, saying that the Foundation has been
unable to provide it with enough sycophants,
and that via the internet, the whole world
will be able to see its face.
If ever 056 got onto YouTube and transformed
into a more successful SCP Channel, I just
don’t think we’d be able to take it!
Thankfully, this request was denied.
Now go check out “SCP Minecraft World Destroyer
SCP-4335 - A Welt In The Crucible” and “SCP-2430
- Immortal Hitler Clone” for more anomalies
you really just wanna punch in the face!